my name is
uh ian hodgnicki i'm a user interface
architect
on the user interface group that's a lot
of user interfaces
um and today i'm going to talk about
our high resolution support in 12 1
and what that means for notebooks
and in particular working with images uh
because that's arguably the the most uh
drastic
um difference um but just really quick
to get started
uh we gotta go over a couple of terms
that may use
and in case you're not familiar with
them uh one
is a desktop publishing point um
which is recognized as being 172nd of
an international inch and this dates
back to really old printing days
a lot of the times people just shorten
that to point
that is exactly what i'm going to use
because
even though our documentation says
printer points it's still one word too
many
um the other key term uh is dots per
inch in pixels per inch
um i won't take a stand on which one
uh it's kind of like vim or emax
but they're both trying to convey the
same thing which is basically
they're trying to describe how many
elements there
are per a phys per physical space um
a lot of the times dots are used with
printers um
and back in you know ye olden days
uh os's would refer to them as dots
still
um ppi is a little bit more modern tend
to be used more for raster devices and
bitmaps
and as you can see down the bottom you
know depending on the density you can
pack more pixels per space they're all
the same size
um but the data that you can represent
inside of them is different
uh the one on the right is uh the
highest quality that my inkjet can
really the inkjet printer can do um the
stuff in the middle is more like forkish
stuff at the lower lower left is more of
the old standard stuff
in 1080p and things like that um
so what exactly does high dpi mean
um and a lot of the times if you ask
that to somebody somebody will say oh
that means it's 4k um
and if you're really into it 5k or 8k um
but really in the end the the actual
designation of it really doesn't matter
um from a software developer's
perspective this is all about supporting
resolution
independence on any device the
desktop front end has always had some
form of resolution independence because
what you saw on screen
uh you know and what you put print to
paper
are two totally different things and yet
they they're wizzywig they match
um you know but in this day and age
it's far more common to have a vastly
wider range
of devices and
i did a quick sampling earlier in the
week you know
working from home i tend to end up using
these devices quite frequently
uh you know my mac my 13 inch macbook
pro
is you know the physically it's 227
that's not actually what apple will run
it at but
that's what it is um the windows devices
the two really low ones are my tvs
um and then the the hundreds and higher
are
my uh 4k and 5k displays um
that's really difficult to work with you
know because devices are all different
so os's will like to coalesce them into
buckets
um which are typically referred to as
logical
dpi or ppi once again i'll use these
interchangeably
uh the mac uh because the uh the mac
actually runs at 144 because it's retina
and that actually works out to be about
right for what they're running it at
windows gets you know my my windows
laptop gets bucketed into you know
either 96 or 128 or 192.
um so they you know they all kind of
coalesce this much wider range
gets funneled down into a much smaller
set
and it's important to know that the
desktop front-end works exclusively in
logical dpi
um and there's reasoning and that that's
tweaked
it simplifies matters in a lot of ways
but it also means
that if you're like well i told it that
i want it to be two inches
and i took my ruler up and it's not two
inches
i always have to ask the question well
what are your settings
because you can drastically alter that
that relationship
um which brings me
to probably the very first oops
very first point of um
of twelve one which is the very first
question i get asked is
what why does twelve one look so
different if i'm on windows or linux
um and the main reason is this in
120 the desktop front end
was not resolution independent
completely
and so it classified all desktop
displays
as being 72 dots per inch translation
if you asked for a font of 12 points
and we drew it to screen it would the
the em
square of it which is the space that a
character could take
uh would be 12 pixels um
and so if you were on a device
where you didn't have a you know 72 dpi
monitor and it was a much higher res
one the os would do bitmap scaling to
bring it up to size so it didn't look
really tiny and you end up with this
really nasty blurring effect
um so you know at 1x which is 72 there
it would be nice and crisp but as you
know the the density goes up
it would blur out now this is
approximate it's not really
fair it's not that bad looking
but it is blurry and people complain
about it rightfully so
um so okay so we fixed that so
you know this great the front end now
understands
you know what the devices dpi setting as
reported by the operating system
and now if you ask for a 12 point font
the em square is almost guaranteed not
to be 12 pixels
but the nice thing is is that the font
size
in you know of cambria 12 in
the front end should match cambria 12 in
word
or cambria 12 in oh i forget what libra
office's name
uh writer i think it's called writer um
you know
it they should match and no matter what
density you have
that text should always look amazing on
it
um so this is all great you know it's
great i have text that's now
clear um and things always look good but
you still haven't answered the question
of why does 12
1 look different um and and the reason
behind that is is that
you know because pixels and points are
no longer a one-to-one correlation
and we actually work off of what the dpi
uh the what the os is telling us things
are now going to
match what they were actually expect to
be we actually
respect the the data that's come back
and while this entire demo
well this entire slide is talking about
font sizes
font sizes is not the only place where
points are actually used in the desktop
front end
um and where are those actually being
these turns out to be just about
everything
um we have a handful of exceptions
um which are in font uh
relative units like ems or line heights
but for the most part all the size and
margin specs
are in points uh so if you spect
an image size as listed here
of you know oh 40 by 40
and you expect it to be 40 pixels it's
no longer going to be 40 pixels
um this is applicable to window size so
if you asked for
a window to be 400 by 300 it is not
going to be 400 pixels by 300 pixels
it's going to be 400 points by 300
points
and if that mean and if you're on that
168
um dpi display that will be a much
larger number
um we do it for directives directives
all the absolute dashing thickness point
size all of those are actually in points
so if you were asking for a line to be
one point
thick expecting it to be one pixel thick
that's no longer going to be the case
and then of course mouse position touch
position
connected displays any function that
would return you something in some kind
of coordinate
those are all in points um and
the reason for this well i mean we're
document
you know the the front end works in
documents uh so it's not
crazy that we would have worked in
something that isn't pixels
um but it's also been this way for since
five two it was fun the other day i
actually brought up the help viewer from
five two to look at the docs and that
was actually a throwback experience
there
um so um a lot of different ways in
which
the coordinates that you might have
assumed had been
one in the same are no longer this are
no longer necessarily the same thing
um so the first question the next
question that a lot of times i get asked
is well okay that's great if you're
telling me i have to work in points
but i have pixels what do i do about
this well i mean it's really
simple and straightforward um you know
it's just a simple scalar the key thing
is you have to know the density um
in order to be able to get back and
forth now working with windows that's
really easy
um you know that's that's that's our
responsibility to deal with
um but you know there's other things
that require
a density like for instance
images you know images are just you know
a two-dimensional array of pixels
um but they also have uh some metadata
in them that tells you approximately how
big that image is supposed to be
and we actually have an example here uh
from the example data you know of some
apples
and if you look at the dimensions
for said image it's 2700 pixels wide
which is actually about two-thirds of
this monitor
maybe you know roughly somewhere in
there um
and it's image resolution you know that
the density of this image is 300 by 300
um so in points that actually works out
to be 648 by 432 and that's
roughly what that displays as on screen
here
so given pixels and the image resolution
you we can automatically figure out what
its natural
image size should be um and
based on you know depending on all the
data necessarily you can tweak what that
visible size is going to be based on
solely based on the density of the image
itself
we also have image resolution which you
can spec
as part of export and rasterize um
so you can get back to the 12-0
behavior by specking that you want the
image resolution to be 72 which is what
the front end
used to be and if you ask for something
that was 81
uh in each dimension you get back
something that where in pixels and in
points they're identical
um you know but now you can also do
something more along the lines of this
is more accurate from my setup
um you know where i want the exact same
plot
uh at the exact same you know image size
and i get 2.667 times more data out of
it
um where it's now 216 by 216.
um and of course you can go further you
know obviously this is my printer this
is my inkjet
running at its default quality and you
get something back that's 405 but all of
these
all have the same physical dimensions
they're all 81 points
for each side which also
illustrates a good point which is image
resolution is a lot like plot points
um you don't need to go crazy in order
to generate a nice looking image like
i've seen
some examples on stack exchange where
it's like oh well i'm going to throw
image resolution of 5000 in there well
i'm not going to do 5000
but i'll do i'll do 2000 you know and
2000
is you know 100 times more data
or 100 times more pixels um
for the exact same visible space which
means you're generating a lot of data
that
technically isn't even going to be
visible because it's being thrown out
well it's not thrown out but it's
blended
and so if you don't need that fidelity
you don't need to jack up the image
resolution that high now if you're doing
something where
it's i'm uh i'm doing some
pre-processing i'm gonna push down to
something else later in the stack and i
need it to be ultra ultra ultra
dense well that's fine there's nothing
wrong with that
um but of course that's also if you're
generating something that's going to be
seen on screen
it's probably not the most optimal way
to go about doing it
you're definitely using a lot more
resources for no real visible
immediately visible gain
so we have image resolution for
rasterizing that's great
you know you can start playing around
with these things on your own
um the problem kind of comes in that
well i have to keep specking
all of this into rasterize it'd be
really nice if i could kind of
you know set it once and for batching
for batch jobs
so we have dollar sign image resolution
which by default is automatic
and the automatic case basically means
ask the front end to render something at
the highest resolution for um
for my display um or for my machine for
my setup
um and
the um uh
this is done primarily because of the
fact that you know we had a couple of
choices that we could have made we could
have left it alone and left it at 72
and then asked rasterize to make ugly
pictures for the rest of time
which you know yes it would have been
consistent with what it did before
um but then also it's a really bad
experience going forward
um when you know the industry is
trending towards denser displays
i didn't want it to be a fixed cap value
because then it's inevitable that you're
always going to blow by a fixed cap
um so in the end we came to this
compromise of let's well let's just do
it for the
most reasonable that's uh that's
currently valid
um or currently would be used um and of
course you know once again
you can totally change it if you so
desire if you want complete control you
got complete control
it's just about what's the we're trying
to make the defaults convenient for
everyone who might not necessarily care
about these things
um once again because this is a global
um you know there's always the problem
of what if there's two people trying to
do the exact same thing
but slightly differently so normally we
recommend using block
to prevent it from leaking out um
so that way you can still get what
you're looking for which is something
different from the default
but it also at the same time doesn't
overflow into everyone else
um and the nice thing about all of this
is is that
this round trips um so
the as long as you're using a lot of the
most common
image formats uh will will you know
export we'll write the metadata in for
the density and import will bring it
back in and it'll get back in the image
and it works its way back in the front
so you can work with these things and
they expect consistency across the board
which is kind of cool downside
is the second well okay maybe it's not
the second most
question but it's certainly up there is
why is my bitmap so small now um
and as a great example of this is uh the
one that comes out of
um well for mouth hood for this case
with zebra
um and as you can see it's really tiny
and 12-0 it wouldn't have been
and the reason of course is is that well
it's 150 pixels wide
at 300 pixels per inch so it's a half an
inch wide
um yeah well that's why
if you're interested in fixing that um
you know obviously you could just wrap
image around it and set image resolution
to be 72
um and that would restore back to the to
the old size that you're most used to
but
this is working off of the metadata so
you know metadata
for these things is important and if
it's not specced i should mention
that if image resolution was omitted
like you had something
pre version like pre version 12 1 um
that the the front end will treat it as
if it was still
as 12-0 so it would go oh okay then
the natural resolution for this uh is 72
then
so it displays at the size that you were
expecting it to because it just
it can't make an educated guess that
what the
density of it would have been um
the next best question well the next
question that comes out is typically why
is my bitmap blurry
um and the easiest answer to that is
normally your your image isn't
running with the same density as your
display
um so for instance here's plot um
you know we have uh we have a very very
um
high desire to keep plot lines really
thin and really sharp
um so you know so it's really thin it's
black
it looks nice and crisp you go through
and rasterize at a much higher
resolution
right all those pixels have to be have
to go somewhere and it's twice as big
but crammed in the same physical space
um and so therefore what happens is you
have two choices you can either
throw pixels away which is generally bad
and looks terrible
or you can blend them all together um
and blending them together is what we do
that isn't cheap by the way so if you're
like oh i'm gonna have my five thousand
by five thousand and squish it down into
a really small
it's not cheap you're doing a lot of
work for for
not very much you don't get very much
out of that work at the end
but nonetheless that's exactly why that
happens
um next biggest question that tends to
come up
um is i was i had this thing
and i'm trying to use graphics
primitives with it and none of this
stuff works
um so good example of that here's an
image that i have
um it's 504 pixels wide
which is 121 points wide we're going to
call it roughly around in there
and i'm going to take uh and i'm going
to drop spot
uh in uh into the image basically
a quarter of the way up another quarter
of the way in from the left hand side
um and lo and behold where's my spot
um and well okay so what what happened
here
well what happens here is that the front
end actually doesn't work with image it
works with boxes
so there's a box that represents an
image and that box has
you know pixel data and it has a range
specification for it
and that range specification is used to
translate between
graphics coordinates and pixels um so as
you can see it's not like the front it
has it wrong
you know the dimensions of the pixel
data is right it's 504 wide
they flipped but they're 504 wide
and the range spec is the points back so
um and then if you look at the plot
range for said graphic that comes out of
it
it's the points back so if you were to
take
if seen that this was a quarter of the
way through
um you take a quarter of 504 and it's
definitely bigger than 120
and a quarter of 378 it's definitely
bigger than 90.
um so my red disc is actually off the
screen
or off the the image itself
so okay what can you do about this well
i mean the two easiest ways
are really for especially for the
synthetic example
is uh one to use points um
you know the the conversion is easy
enough because you know the density of
the image
you can do all of this yourself um
without any real work
and of course now your spot you know the
red spot is now back where it should be
um you can also use scaled i mean
because scale is really easy because now
you don't even care what the coordinate
spaces are you just know it's a quarter
of the way in
um obviously that doesn't always work
scaled coordinates isn't always right
but
but certainly you can you know the
transforms
are simple enough if you need to go if
you want it to be placed in points
or in pixels um the front end isn't
going to do that for you automagically
you have to do the work to do it um but
once again these are just
transforms uh to switch coordinate
spaces so it's
it's theoretically possible if you
wanted to but it's much easier to just
do
and convert it into uh pixels or use
scaled
or sorry points are you still um
you know and but this this actually came
up enough
um that i actually talked with brenton
some
and got it added into um
into his linter so you can actually run
through a bit of code and it will
actually it has a rule in it that will
go through and if it sees
image dimensions on the right hand side
of image size
it's going to flag that as potentially
being a bug
and you should be looking at it now the
confidence level on this
is not the default um
and and because there is a there is a
case where this actually is correct
um so that's why it's a little low i'm
going to talk about that case here in a
second
um but certainly this is a good way to
help you find out places where this
assumption
that points pixels from an
from an image directly map to image size
uh where that is now no longer the case
um and if you're interested to know more
about the
uh the linting stuff you can check out
brenton's talk last year
uh from the tech conference uh about
finding bugs
uh which is really good he had a
workshop earlier this week
where i'm certain that must have come up
in so that you can totally check out
the last interesting example the one i
want to bring up
is using image
as a replacement for calling rasterize
because wrapping something with image
is um is really is really convenient
um and a lot of people have done that um
but there's an interesting quirk with it
um which makes it hard to to recommend
people to use
now on zoom i don't know how well this
comes through
um but the thin line is kind of
important so
the left hand one is the graphics
primitive itself
the raw graphics primitives the one in
the middle is the result of calling
of wrapping it with the image and the
one on the right is calling it with
rasterize now the one in the middle
is all grayed out and the one on the
right looks
way more like the one on the left now
why is that well
using image with image size is
effectively
like calling rasterize where your image
type spec gets passed into raster size
and the image resolution is fixed to 72.
now i didn't actually
look at the how it's implemented so
don't this is not a direct oh this is
how it's implemented
i have no idea but this is the actual
implications of what it's doing
um so that has some interesting things
because
now if you start messing with image as a
rapper it starts doing some interesting
things that you're probably not
expecting
one i asked for this graphics primitive
to be
a disc that's 81 by 81
points um and i'm going to give it an
image resolution i want it to be at 168
which is actually the
density of this display and if i ask for
the image dimensions of it
um well it's my 81 pixels
and that should be obvious looking above
the image resolution of 72. there's a
one-to-one correlation with it
okay um but now if i if i were to ask
for the same thing in points
which i would have expected if it was
rasterized at 72
it's not 72 it actually reports it's 168
because i
told it it's supposed to be 168. so now
i get a much smaller point size
what's effectively happened here is the
image resolution of 168 was
overriding what it actually rasterized
at
so you can get yourself into the state
where you have a result that is half
in half out um and basically you know if
if
if you don't care about the end result
of what your rasterizing your
rasterizing is maybe using it for some
data step and it does what it needs to
do for you
then it's fine but if you care about you
know oh i needed to be at this
resolution and i needed to be at this
size and i need all this stuff
image as a rapper isn't the way to go
rasterize is the way you get exactly
what you want
in a consistent form every single time
so based on
some of that once you start working with
points a lot
in places and and thinking of them as
points as opposed to pixels um there's a
couple of interesting things that come
up immediately as being well maybe these
aren't exactly
the smoothest things it'd be really cool
if we could do something about it
um and you know i'm putting some of
these out here none of these are in 12-2
sorry
um but these are a handful of things
that
that we've been tossing over thinking
about it'd be really good to get some
feedback on which ones you think are
more important than others
um so
forgot to close that so the first one is
obvi the most obvious one is quantity
um you know who wants to think
necessarily if i have to think of things
in physical space
why am i thinking of them in terms of
this arcane
72nd of an inch kind of thing why can't
i think of it much more natural things
um and so getting units like centimeters
inches and millimeters
this build actually does this i've a
build that's my own personal one this
build can actually do this for image
size
um which is actually kind of cool but i
mean it should be applicable to way more
than just image size
um typographic units um
you know i expect that to be in there
because twips are used quite frequently
pikas are used some i'm sure there's a
handful of others out there that would
be interesting to do that i haven't even
thought of yet
um relative units is actually probably
the most interesting one to me
um because it allows you to do it allows
you to sign
size things according to the ambient
font
um which we've actually done uh
we've actually internally done for a
handful of things
if you were if you saw john's talk
earlier
um he was talking about using template
box for
uh uh for replay updating the the boxes
the type setting for rgb color
and the the boxes for rgb color are
trying to do this
um and it would be way cooler if you
could just go
oh well it's it's it's just i need to be
the size relative to the font
um which would be kind of cool um dpi
it's
itself is uh it's kind of an old
you know it dates back quite a ways um
you know
there's other alternatives i mean
obviously the most natural one is well
if it's inches why is it in centimeters
why is it metric so being able to expect
that metric
um i don't know if you could convince me
that
dot pitch is a good idea um but if you
feel strongly about it
um i'd certainly be interested in uh in
hearing your case for it
um you know once we start talking about
you know oh the problem of i rasterize
it as
a specific resolution it moves to a
different place now it
it might not look as ideal i want to be
able to to compensate for that
um you know then we start talking about
multi-image support
which is most often in 2d 3d world it's
most often
referred to as mipmaps you know level of
detail
in one single image which is really cool
we've been talking about that for 3d
graphics anyways
but you know in 2d it now actually
becomes a big deal because i thought
about doing this for
notebooks um and saving
multiple we cache expensive graphics
that take a long time to render we cache
them
and it'd be really kind of cool if it
actually could cache multiples of them
uh so that way it always looked right no
matter where you went so that's kind of
cool
um you know another way of doing this is
the thing called
we call or calling dynamic assets um
basically it's a way to load external
data in situ
that's the simplest way to put it the
the more obvious example is like if you
look at like the new opening cloud
dialogue like those buttons that say
okay and cancel
you know the okay one is red and has
stylized and the cancel
it has a different style to it all
together we use like a precursor of this
internally today and we've been talking
about
you know formalizing it and bringing it
up so
it's well documented and people can use
it themselves and this is a nice way
once again to be like oh i need this
image
but i want the one that's specific for
this exact environment
which is kind of cool and be useful to
use um
and then if you i'm going to guess a lot
of people said huh
when they saw this come up um because i
don't understand the
the the correlation between the two um
high dpi support
resolution independence i should say is
actually a prerequisite in order to get
gesture handling on touch screens in
on like on windows specifically um
you know mac that was probably already
there and it would have been fine
linux i'm not 100 sure on on that one
but certainly
getting windows to do it um you know we
had to get resolution independence which
is you know
kind of cool you know some people have
been asking for it um
but now that we actually can get to the
point where we can really you know build
this out it'd be nice to know how many
people are actually interested in this
um you know certainly you know getting
supporting for penn that's come up and
and touch you know um is uh
is an interesting thing to deal with as
well so
um that's it for my talk
i only ran three minutes long so that's
pretty good
i consider that a win um uh certainly we
can i'm gonna go through the
chat now we'll keep this on and i'll
just read these out well maybe i don't
know
what's easier best on that um but most
definitely
if you uh think of something afterwards
we're doing an office hour
in like two and a half hours um
where it's me john uh lou d'andrea
uh i think parth will be there too so if
you got questions about the front end
why it does something i really hate this
behavior why haven't you guys bothered
to fix this
um you know totally bring it up um at
that point as well
uh and cool so thank you very much
uh i'm gonna go through and and go
through the chat and uh
and hope you guys have a pleasant rest
of the day